اذا تلجا الصين لمحاوله اختراق شبكات
البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه بحسب شركه
مايكروسوفت عملاق التقنيه الامريكيه اعلن
رصد نشاط سيبراني تنفذه مجموعه صينيه هذه
المجموعه تدعى
التي قالت مايكروسوفت انها تحظى برعايه
رسميه من السلطات الصينيه كما حضرت
مايكروسوفت من ان الهجوم يهدد باحداث
اضطرابات في البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
للاتصالات بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسيا في المستقبل واوضحت مايكروسوفت
اربعه تكتيكات تستخدمها فولتايفون لمهاجمه
مؤسسات تعمل في قطاعات الاتصالات والصناعه
وايضا التعليم التكتيك الاول يعتمد على
جمع البيانات بما في ذلك بيانات الانظمه
المحليه والشبكات المرتبطه بها ليتم بعد
ذلك في المرحله الثانيه وضع هذه البيانات
في ملفات ارشيفيه متسلسله التكتيك
تعمد او تعمد المجموعه الصينيه الى
استخدام البيانات المسروقه وافساح المجال
لامكانيه الوصول اليها اخيرا تقوم فولت
تايفون بدمج انظمتها ضمن نطاق عمل الشبكات
في المؤسسات التي تم اختراقها وتوجيح حركه
مرور البيانات عبر الشبكه صينيه لتسهيل
الدخول اليها وقت الحاجه بدورها قالت
وكاله الامن القومي الامريكي ان المجموعه
الصينيه تستخدم ادوات مدمجه في الشبكات
للتهرب من رصدها وعدم ترك اي اثر خلفها ما
يصعب امر اكتشاف هذه التقنيات كما وضعت
الوكاله ارشادات فنيه للشركات التي تعمل
في قطاع البنيه التحتيه لتحديد النشاطات
الخبيثه او الضاره واحتمال وجود اختراقات
من قبل فولت ايفون لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات